can't believe I'm gonna talk about this
but you know what we're going to make it
a teachable moment no Star Wars act like
has not been canceled this was a show
that recently announced the casting of
Abigail Thorne now there is a rumor that
it has been canceled and funnily enough
that rumor started immediately after uh
her Casting was announced and the reason
I know it's not true is because it's
sourced from this guy The Alkali itself
is soft canceled that guy's name Doom
I'm not kidding and that is how he
actually presents himself I didn't alter
that footage his entire uh model here on
YouTube is to basically just say what he
wishes would happen and hope that
eventually his anti-walk narrative will
happen to come true in certain instances
and he can claim that he knew and that
he called it he's been saying Kathleen
Kennedy has been fired or is about to be
fired from uh lucasfilm for literally
years and then stuff like this gets
regurgitated by Outlets that are pure
click bait and do not care to vet their
stories and just put up anything that is
rumored on the off chance it turns out
to be true so no there's a reason that
uh respectable sites aren't
regurgitating this